ANA BELL: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So I have here--
first part is just the top part,
so I have some blank
line and then I'm
defining a method name speak.
So write a line to
replace blank that
creates a class for a Dog
that inherits from Animal.
So the first thing
I notice is that I
need to write a definition
for a class whose name is Dog.
So my choices are these.
So I can tell it's either
the first or the third one.
And then I want to
inherit from Animal,
so I don't want to
inherit from object
but I want to inherit
from Animal, right?
So that's perfect.
Next question says, with
this definition of Dog,
you run a program with
those three lines.
What happens?
So this is my definition and
I have these three lines.
Let's go down here.
Nice.
OK.
So with these three lines,
this first line says,
d is equal to Dog 7.
So I'm creating a Dog
object with age 7.
Is this line going
to throw an error?
Well, this line actually
looks for an init method.
This particular class definition
doesn't have a init method,
but hey, I'm inheriting
from someone.
I'm inheriting from Animal.
Does Animal have an init method?
And it does, as we
saw in the slides.
OK, so we're creating a new
Dog with age 7 and name none.
So that line doesn't
throw an error.
The next line sets
the name to Ruffles.
And again, I don't
have a set name
method inside this
particular class,
but does my Animal
class-- my parent class--
have a set name method?
And yes it does-- right here.
So I call that one.
So that line does
not throw an error.
And the third line
says d.speak, which
is going to cause Python to
look in this current class
definition.
And it says, hey, I have
a method here named speak,
so I'm going to use this one.
And it's going to print ruff
ruff, because it's a method,
so you can just--
it's like a function.
You can just print things.
You don't need to
return anything.
So, perfect, most of you
are getting that right.